what are you doing are you trying to
stay
uh in shape during quarantine that's a
struggle for a lot of people
i uh i've uh been i've given up
bread well kind of i've i've been trying
to eat healthy and my wife bought me a
scale
oh you know she loves me
you know she bought me a scale and so i
tried the scale and it's like one of
those where it works on your phone and
it keeps track of how fat you get and so
i stood on the scale and i looked at the
app and it's
it's in metric because the whole world
is in metric but it was like really
small type and i was with my
16 year old and there was this red line
and i was like did does that say
finished
you know and my uh 16 year old goes no
it says
obese so you got an obese rating
i'm obese
you know what i would say is just just
turn off the phone or delete the app
that's one way you don't that's not
necessarily bad
right um
no it's not necessarily bad it's not the
best
obese can mean it's a health risk you
got to take care of yourself jim
people are counting on you oh god
who's calling you it was it was it was
no one
okay just quickly i'm getting something
here
hello yeah conan
yes i can yes jim jim um
can talking through into the vegetables
it was fun the first time
the second time third time it started
worth in
um now it's really it's probably
at all well i think if you do it a
little more it's gonna start to get
really funny
do you think this oh you know what this
one's out of batteries
you've had that mug since late the late
show right
it was called late night i know you're a
fan uh
excuse me i didn't want to you know 1993
93 yeah you weren't even born
when i was i was very young oh here i
got a good story
so um i went to georgetown university
and so i was doing this fundraiser in
philadelphia
and um i arrived at the fundraiser and
there was this woman
in her 30s and uh she was running the
whole
um production and she was like you went
to georgetown i went to georgetown and i
was like oh wow
there you go and so then later on i was
talking to her
and she said what year did you graduate
and i go i graduated in 88 and she said
oh my gosh
that's the year i was born
chilling right it was just brutal i'm
just an
old old zucchini holder
you know i get this a lot like a 17 year
old
kid will come up to me and go like oh my
god i can't believe it's you conan
it's so amazing can i get a selfie this
is back when you could take selfies and
i'd be like
yeah you seem excited and you went well
my grandmother watched you when she was
a little
girl that's what i get my grandmother
watched you when she was a little little
girl just off the boat from italy
in the 1920s that's what i get no it's
brutal
it's terribly brutal um
have you ever get this you ever have
anyone say that you remind them a little
bit of john malkovich
because when you were when you were
talking about the garden you went
you started talking about i like my
garden and it's where i like to go
and your lips did a thing and your whole
affect became like john malkovich did
you
did you realize that i see you standing
over the grave of another dead president
no i um yes i love that movie in the
line of fire
yes well he's he's from the midwest and
i'm from the midwest
and we're i used to have a more nasally
voice
but i think it got beaten out of me no
but um
yeah john malkovich when you you'll
you'll say i
i mean i don't do a john malkovich
impression but but
you purse your lips in a little bit and
then there's an accent when you say the
west
and it's just john malkovich that's so
brilliant
but you know what's weird he's yeah he's
brilliant he's brilliant
he's the good yes he's the one i wish i
was talking to
right well you know the amazing but then
again what about that
that apple tv show he's got to regret
that
anyway but um the
uh but the weird thing is john malkovich
he has a little bit of a whine
you know like do you ever sometimes
see comments where people are like oh
this guy sounds
so uh feminine like do i have an
effeminate voice i mean you have a very
effeminate voice but you already know
that
like do you ever hear that do people are
like do you think you have
i never get that i have people think
that i have a
it's a little bit pitched high tenor but
they think i have a commanding sort of
jfk
affect where i'm taking us to the next
generation
yeah i've never you have a very
i'm very my binary
but i didn't realize i had i didn't
realize
i had a feminine voice i mean not as
effeminate as yours
you know what i mean but like uh again
i think we've established that i have a
commanding
um presidential and i'm talking about
1962
is that we'll go to the moon
not because it's easy but because it's
hard
you have more of a my garden my garden
i think i'll be in my garden
like when you carry around a book
because you don't have friends do you
find the book heavy
uh it's the gutenberg bible uh it's very
heavy
it's uh it's encased in in lead to
protect it
so i'm very strong you know i'm very
strong
there's a lot of things you i mean you
you're way more talented
like you can play guitar but we're both
very goofy looking people
but we've done so well given what we
look like
i mean look at us we've done great i am
in an abandoned theater
that no one wants to be in because
they're afraid of kovid and you're at a
sizzler steakhouse
i liked how they whispered sizzler like
it was this secret
santa says
where did you throw up